you know what's crazy I'm not going to
say this in this interview because I say
it every in every interview ever my
parents don't know what I do and they
live like 10 minutes away
they're gonna find out that I won't
how could they not know the Internet is
just so big
yeah that's a problem it is it's so it's
so big
and if you're just not in that world
it's like
you're just not in it if you don't watch
porn you wouldn't have known I did porn
well I guess that's true yeah
how long have you been doing porn
I've been making my own porn for about
two years
so two years
you only been doing it for two years so
I started doing porn
um in 2019 during covid mostly because I
just wanted residual income like I
wanted to be able to just stay at home
and work remotely and not actually enter
an office space
um but I was just a horny [__]
depraved Twisted person like way long
before that like I used to throw parties
like sex parties and I would just get
[__] on the mattress on the floor in
front of like all these guys just
jacking off and like all these dudes
just [__] me and that was before you
were in independent yeah that was way
before porn and then I would throw like
sex parties like every Friday and have a
bunch of people come over and I just
like like
I luckily was able to do this in a place
that made me feel really safe and
honestly
was really great about consent and
establishing boundaries so even though
it was a crazy sexual experience I felt
like I was able to really explore my
sexuality in a safe way where I didn't
really feel judged or like had to
experience consequences for being
hypersexual
so you've always been a very sexual
yeah and and I feel like I just like
love Horrors like when a [__] would be
on the TV screen I would just like be
inspired by her I would find her so
powerful I would really see so much
power in her yeah I've heard that from
some of the sex workers I've interviewed
they said even when they were like seven
years old they
saw something about like a stripper or a
strip club or something to do with sex
and they that's for me yeah I just
gravitate towards it and I feel like
it's just so fun to make people feel
good
it's interesting
what was your childhood like see people
always ask what my childhood is like and
they expect like some crazy abusive
traumatic story as if people just can't
be twisted and disgusting just because
they want to be like there needs to be
some moral justification for why I like
gang bangs
um my family life was pretty normal my
parents kicked me out when I was 19 but
a lot of people get kicked out when
they're 19 and they don't end up like me
you know I feel like sexually I just
always wanted to experience more and
more and more and more and I feel like
people are the best books and I'll try
anything twice and as long as I did it
safely and consensually and ethically I
didn't feel like there was anything
wrong with doing anything in excess as
long as my goals were still being met
yeah you get a lot of flack in the
comments section because you are such a
sexual
overtly sexual young lady yeah dude do
you feel like sex is uh you know
Americans are just uptight about sex I
do think because you're not hurting
anybody you're right I don't think I'm
hurting anybody yeah I'll get a slew of
negative comments when I talk about like
how hypersexual I am as if that's like
as if like I represent something evil
like something they can't control and
that makes them just really [__] mad
and I feel like with the Advent of more
and more women especially becoming more
comfortable with their sexuality and
making more informed choices about what
they want to do with their body I feel
like it makes a lot of people mad
because it makes them insecure because
they don't they don't know what else
they can offer if I've already
experienced squirting or deep throating
or gang bangs like what else can I offer
and it just means that you have to focus
on on yourself and making sure that we
have shared values and you see me as a
person
how old are you I'm 25. 25. so you're
still very young yeah I started sex
parties when I was 19.
um and I
it was really fun like throwing these
like sex parties every Friday because
everyone started becoming best friends
like we would all go get tested together
we would all get dinner together spend
birthdays dinners
um important life moments together and
it was like one big family where we all
just had sex with each other
sounds fun
was there a uh any kind of abuse in your
childhood that would lead you down this
road
I would say hypersexual
there was never really any abuse in my
childhood
I would just say my parents were
extremely strict I wasn't allowed
outside till I turned 17 so after school
I went to bell rang my parents were
already there ready to pick me up I
wasn't allowed to go outside during the
weekends the holidays summer time I was
just at home making sure I was a good
girl
um getting good grades and doing
everything I'm supposed to do and I
didn't have a phone until I turned 18. I
feel like
my parents must have known I was
different or
I don't know I remember holding a boy's
hand in the eighth grade and my dad saw
and he sent me to a different School
District in a different city and I
wasn't allowed to have any social media
anything
sexual would have been like
yeah so I feel like
you know I was always questions like
you're going to get pregnant and then
you're going to go to jail and you're
just going to be a loser so just make
sure you're not around that [__] at all
and I don't know if that was just his
Assumption of me or if I already was
just a really sexual person so that
would have been obvious but
I feel like I know myself really well
and I have sex with people that respect
me and as long as I'm having sex with
people that respect me even if it's a
[__] ton of people I feel like there's
nothing wrong with that
do you have friends that disapprove of
this lifestyle of yours or have you
weeded those friends out of your life
when they talk to me and get to know me
and see that I'm like [__] sentient
and this isn't like a response to
anything traumatic in my life they
realize it's like sex doesn't always
have to have consequences
um and and so they realize it's not that
big of a deal or such a bad thing to
want sex or like to make sex and have a
bunch of people watch sex are you making
a good living I'm making a really good
living really and I mean I feel like
we're lucky right now because if the
Advent of only fans and becoming an
independent content creator people are
able to do exactly what they want to do
while cutting the middleman out you know
I'm not part of an agency I don't have a
pimp I'm just doing exactly what I want
to do and finding my Niche and whoever
wants to see me get [__] knows where
they can see that
and that doesn't affect you emotionally
it doesn't make you feel like any shame
or anything like that no if I if I could
do this all if my lifestyle didn't
change I would do this all for free I I
feel like it's a great attitude this
this fulfills me and makes me happy to
make people horny
it makes me happy to broaden
perspectives and Horizons and I feel
like a lot of people don't have healed
perspectives on sex they don't want to
like sex too much they don't want to see
too much of it because they're afraid of
the person they'll become if they are
exposed to Too Much sexuality you know
they I feel like a lot of the times
people's argument argument with me is
you know like well what's next like what
are you gonna do that's crazier like as
if there's like like a progressive
linear
path of sexuality where I'm just going
to go nuts and like now I'm gonna get
fisted and now I'm gonna get Triple gang
bang and I want to [__] random
[__] people you know like it's like
that's not I'm going to do exactly what
I want to do and I feel like
people are afraid of that because it's
hot the bravest thing you can do is
to be completely yourself and I feel
like women like me that love sex
represent
like the like proof of consonant you can
love all the parts of yourself all the
disgusting nasty parts that the world
wants to say that I shouldn't deserve
love or I shouldn't be taken seriously
because they don't love that part about
themselves
and and I hope people learn to love all
of themselves even the gross parts and
even the parts the world says that you
shouldn't
you seem to be making good money
you enjoy your work
you feel like you're
breaking ground a little bit with with
advancing New Attitudes right yeah what
are the downsides of of your life
the downsides of my life
lifestyle of my lifestyle
I would say you have to think about it
maybe there aren't any
yeah I would say right now I'm really
lucky but I have to
make it clear like I'm an extremely
privileged position where my story
happened to resonate with a lot of
people and I had a good look and I'm
privileged enough to be
you know in Los Angeles where people
give opportunities to people that look
like me but
sex work isn't all amazing for everyone
you know as we've seen stories on this
channel of people who are sex workers
and it's a very traumatic experience and
it's hurtful
um
obviously being a sex worker will always
come with social stigmas you know I find
myself
to be successful in terms of numbers but
a lot of people still think I'm not
worth that respect you know it's still
hard for me to get an apartment it's
still hard for you know some certain
people to think I'm smart or
multifaceted and nuanced and as long as
we play these respectability politics
and not really
question who creates these standards of
what's acceptable or not people like me
will always be in danger no matter how
much money I make no matter how visible
I am or how pretty I am I'm still
I I'm still so offensive to so many
parts of the world and you know so many
people
hate me and people like me because I
represent something they can't control
and I just feel like
I don't know why why [__] can't change
the world why Horrors like me that are
disgusting they're like triple dicks in
their ass can't be just as worthy of of
thoughts and intelligence and empathy as
as anyone else and sometimes we don't
have to rationalize why we're depraved
and twisted and want to lick a [__]
toilet seat sometimes I just want to
[__] do that
you know and it's and it's not about
making sense all the time it's just
about feeling good and being safe
enjoy this what you do yeah and I feel
like a thing I like about Los Angeles is
that I am a really gross sex worker [__]
bag but that's not the most interesting
part about me and that's what this is
all about right is like I'm all these
dirty things but
that are shocking and you know easy easy
to exploit but there's so many other
things about me that aren't as easily
digestible for the internet that may not
go viral or may not get views but are
still just as valid as every other part
of me you're probably a great neighbor
I'm I'm a horny neighbor yeah
and you had romantic relationships in
your your own life I'm in an open
relationship right now over three years
and um I'm really happy because
I it's kind of crazy a lot of people
love my partner when they meet them
because
they're they always say I I could never
do what you do dude I could never love a
woman like that I could never
do that that's you must be such a strong
person to date someone like that and I
feel like people don't understand like
how
how I would internalize something like
that but it's honestly unfortunately
something that I'm used to and a lot of
people like me are used to is that the
world rubs in our rubs it in our face
how how dirty they think they are and
how we don't deserve love
and honestly it's it's it's possible
it's possible to have your cake and eat
it too it's possible to have the
relationship Dynamic you want without
sacrificing your dignity or compromising
values to yourself
interesting do you what nationality are
you is your family I'm Philip Warfield
we're Filipino you're Filipino yeah are
Filipinos typically like how a lot of
Asian
families will be super strict with their
with their children yeah my parents were
super strict I mean I had a tracking
device on my phone until I was like 21
22.
um
my parents kicked me out when I was 19
because my curfew was 10 and I got home
at 10 30 and they kicked me out and I
stayed with my ex-boyfriend
who was my boyfriend at the time and he
cheated on me and then he kicked me out
and so I was chronically unhoused for
um
a few years of my life just kind of on
and off sometimes finding a place
sometimes living in a co-op sometimes
um having my Elite an apartment but
never for too long I'm stable now and I
feel like
those chap that chapter of my life is
really important to me because I felt
like my life was wholly dependent on how
much a man liked me directly and not on
my own career and my own goals and I
feel like Financial Independence
Financial Independence and owning your
own money especially as a woman is so
important because I want
women to be
wanted and not needed I want if a
situation is bad for me I want to know
that I can leave
if a situation is bad for me I don't
want to feel like I need this guy
even if he disrespects me and hurts me
um to live so I feel like I'm really
happy because everything in my life is
something I want and not something I
need I I can you know I can I only do
what I want I don't have to do anything
I don't want to do now
sex work just a discovery that you
realize I can pay the bills this way I
can get a roof over my head sex work was
something I feel like I was just I would
say I wouldn't even say I was doing for
free for such a long time it was just my
calling it was something I wanted to do
I loved having sex and I love telling
stories and I love expressing myself and
I loved it when people watched and that
was my hobby and luckily it also paid my
last job before this I was in direct
marketing as a marketing executive and I
would go door to door and they would and
business to business they would send me
to Skid Row they would send me to Jordan
downs and I would really just be in
people's faces all the time day in and
day out and I feel like that trained me
to kind of like not give as much of a
[__] because it's such an
like like I was intense you know I was I
was actually having extended
conversations with people who were so
much more different than me and
sex work during covid I just didn't want
to do that anymore I didn't want to go
outside I when it was quarantine time I
also wanted to buy some [__] titties
and I did
after I found out how I could make money
selling my own content and that was
content that
was stuff I like to do anyways it was
and I feel like that's the whole beauty
of it all right it's like you know that
it's ethically sourced and ethically
created it's it's not something that's
like
not real it's something I just wanted to
do and I'm just letting you in the porn
industry has changed a lot in the last
10 years or so right yeah where do you
make most of your money on only fans
yeah I make most of my money on only
fans because
I mean
that that that's me that's my source
that's I'm not cutting a middleman I
shoot as much as I want I'm shooting
right after this
I I do Post every day I would say yeah I
post every day and I I make a video
and making videos is awesome because I
just I would just message someone I
would want to have sex with and then we
just have amazing sex and then I record
it and then people buy it and it's it's
awesome it almost doesn't even feel real
because I feel like the world tells us
that you're supposed to suffer you're
supposed to have a consequence at some
point something bad is supposed to
happen to you and and it's not happening
I'm just I'm just really at peace with
myself you're making good money you're
having a good time you're not hurting
anybody
yeah it seems to make perfect sense
I I've done a little bit of mainstream
porn I signed a vixen but even then I it
was just like being on a normal movie
setup is that is that part of the
industry over
I wouldn't say it's over I feel like
right now
I would love it if everyone in the world
at least fought about jacking off to me
once you know like I like doing
mainstream because you just get way more
eyes it's a great commercial to seeing
what I'm capable of and obviously it
would bring you to my only fans or my
other sites where you see how I make
porn myself when it's just me in my room
you know making something that I'm
directly passionate about but I like
mainstream porn because
even though it's a little archaic to me
um in terms of like you show up you get
paid one time and then
boom it's it's still a fun it's still
probably the primary means that people
consume porn because it's the most
easily accessible only fans makes it
where the money goes into your pocket
mostly yeah and I'm and you're in
control of it yeah and I'm control of
all of it so when people have issues
because it's like what what are you
actually mad about the fact that because
it's not like you don't consume porn
or or you never have and inherently I
don't think porn is wrong I I think
anything done in excess is that that
takes you away from your goals and your
focus and what makes you happy can be
detrimental and that's bad for you but I
don't think
as long as you understand the
differences between reality and and fit
and fiction you understand that porn is
entertainment and not meant to be
educational or a supplement for real
life relationships
what is it that
that you like so much about sex because
you sound like a very sexual girl right
I I love I feel like I understand
pleasure and for me I I like sex where I
feel vulnerable and I feel seen I feel
like
like understanding the language of
another person and and seeing how to
express themselves with their body is
something so beautiful and oftentimes
it's the most vulnerable you'll ever see
someone I mean obviously we could have
conversations that are a million times
more vulnerable than what you can share
with your body but it's something that I
feel like
it's it's just it's it's just me getting
like us becoming
a thing you know it's just it's a moment
you know and I wouldn't say that all sex
is amazing I would say like whatever
sexual
whatever interaction you have of another
person or yourself
has just as much value as you directly
give it so if I want to have sex with
you and I feel like this would be
important to me then of course it would
be important and it'd be amazing and if
it wasn't important to me then it's just
a thing we did and it's just a moment
but it doesn't take away from my value
or add or add to it it's just a thing I
do I do
hmm
and you
where do you see yourself going in in
five or ten years what would you like to
be doing
actual property of my content so for
that's great so as long as anyone wants
to watch a video of me getting [__] I
will always make money off of it now
will I always actively be creating porn
with my physically maybe not I probably
will be using that money that I've
invested into other projects and I feel
like
sex work for me has offered has offered
me the ability to wear many hats like
obviously I'm doing this podcast I'm
getting better at speaking to people I'm
growing skill sets because I'm now
financially stable and I have the time
to explore those resources
and I do want to say like as another
disclaimer I am again in an extremely
privileged position as a successful sex
worker that makes a lot of money but
all sex workers deserve money even when
I was selling [__] for 200 even when I
was getting [__] on the mattress on
the floor we all deserve respect and
it's horror for horror for horror for
[__] no matter what I like even the
girl even the people that don't look
respectable even the people that you
know are doing it for fun or doing it
for sad reasons or doing it for whatever
the [__] reason that they're doing it
for all sex workers deserve respect and
they deserve the feeling of feeling safe
so you you were selling sex
I was a sugar baby super briefly and not
even
as a thing like for like a maybe a small
chapter of my sex worker Hood
and it mostly was
just a
it mostly was a form of self-exploration
for me like I I did a lot of doming work
I did a lot of like dinners I did a lot
of tge to girlfriend experience I mostly
just love to have a good story and I'll
try anything twice so I I found a lot of
joy and experiences like that even if
they just because I liked the story do
you have siblings yeah I have a little
better
are you the black sheep of the family I
think my parents my parents think I'm a
[__] loser I think the the whole
world probably thinks I'm like a giant
[__] loser because I dropped out of
college and they don't really know what
I'm doing more money than your dad yeah
absolutely I mean I spoil my dad me and
my dad had beef because he kicked me out
when I was 19. but we finally have such
a good relationship now because it looks
like I'm doing well and I am doing well
what does he think you're doing just
social media influencing just that's
what you're doing yeah I mean that's
what I am doing right and then I happen
to also make porn
and I'm happy but he'll never understand
that and sometimes it hurts that you
know I want to share these
accomplishments like I won an awarded
expose or I got on Playboy and I can't
share these experiences with him but I
never really did so I guess it's fine
what do you wish was different about
your relationship with your parents you
wish they could open up their minds a
bit I
I feel like I don't think they ever
would open up their minds so I've never
even entertained that so
it's like we our relationship is finally
okay
and it's it used to be really not okay
for a long time there was so much pain
between us when they kicked me out and
then me finally getting back home and
you know like now I'm suddenly you know
on my feet living in a penthouse and my
retirement's maxed out and life is
perfect and I got tits now and
um
I I just can't imagine my parents being
open-minded and loving me
unconditionally like that and that's
kind of crazy but I don't feel I feel
like most parents wouldn't love their
kid if they knew how [__] and dirty
they were
some could
some do yeah hats off to them but yeah
my I just feel like I'm afraid that the
moment I tell my parents you know this
small window of us being happy is is
gone and it's like wow I really should
have just never said anything since you
know obviously you give a [__] about
[__] like that
and and tell me about some of the
exploits you'll get into you do some
extreme sexual things right yeah not
that I want all the details you want all
the details what they're called gang
bangs yeah I mean I used to watch porn
so I don't really know but this wasn't
for porn This was
um I've heard about it just for fun I
mean I
I've been to many
sex parties or I've been to many I like
to explore subcultures so if you're a
furry and you want to you identify as an
anthropomorphic dog I want to understand
you because I I feel like we should
learn to see things we don't understand
and not want to destroy them so I
explored a lot of sexual things I've
been to footnites I've been to BDSM
shows I've been to sex parties and my
favorite thing has always been gangbangs
I just [__] love them it's just
people don't understand from a woman's
perspective because a lot of women won't
openly say they want to do gang bangs
but it just feels so empowering like
everyone's here for me like that really
feeds into my narcissism you know it's
like wow everyone's here for my pleasure
everyone wants to make me feel good this
isn't like a rough porn style gangbang
where people are just using my [__]
like a [__] human flashlight unless
that's what I want like these are people
who are asking hey do you want to have
sex and I'm just agreeing to like 10 of
them at the same time so it would be
like us going into a hotel suite or us
going into like just a secret sex party
and you intend guys
I would just go by myself and there just
would happen to be a lot of guys
and you know in the hotel yeah in a
hotel you just say hey you want to come
in and
we would they would post it online on
these ads and stuff or like there would
be a Text Blast once you were in like a
membership group and and you're charging
for that or you're not no I wasn't
charging for that I I want to only have
sex I want to have which in this context
like
at some point people offered me money
and I just kind of was like I'll take it
but I I wanted to just do it anyways it
made me happy it still makes me happy
it's not something I really do right now
because I'm so responsible with my porn
like you're busy yeah I get tested every
five to seven days I don't have sex with
strangers like that anymore but it was a
crazy chapter of My Life
um
and I made a lot of friends like I
remember like the funniest thing ever
would be like you know after I [__]
all these guys I'd be like hey I'm
hungry let's all go get Korean barbecue
let's all go get dinner and it'd be me
with like eight guys and we would all
just be eating dinner together like one
big [__] date like I feel like
people I wish people could see the fun
and how silly it all is do you ever
develop
a connection with anyone yeah yeah
there's definitely guys that I'm still
friends with to this day that you know
their lives have moved on and so have I
it it's when people just realize it's
just an act and not
and not like a disgusting like crime
against humanity it's it's it's just
like who [__] cares you know I've
like seen I actually remember going to
dinner with this guy and this girl that
was also getting gang banged and they're
married now you know like well that's
such a [__] interesting story you
know you met at the gang bang and I
watched him have sex and you know I saw
it all and I participated and and once
people realize that you know sometimes
you can have sex because you want to and
it's fun and you're not supposed to
suffer I I feel like more people will
have fun with with exploring who they
are and not having to rationalize like a
relationship or or any or respect for
sex just have sex because you want to as
long as you're doing it like safely
because they're just I know there's
going to become some comments saying
This Girl Is Lost and she's confused and
she's Disturbed and
I know I know I can already guess the
comments are gonna be like this girl is
[__] deranged I cannot wait for the
moment that she falls and I always like
want to ask those people
and then what if it doesn't happen you
know what what if I never reach my
comeuppance and I'm not I'm not and I
think these you have to understand the
comments especially on the social media
platform like this and YouTube you they
reflect more about the person than the
person they're commenting about
you have to understand that yeah so
there's something
deeply unhappy about the person that's
saying these things yeah no I I look at
your story you know here I am looking at
you I'm not judging you I'm not I I
would say
she owns her sexuality she's making good
money
she's doing it safely she's not hurting
anybody
let her let her have her fun let her do
her thing you're probably gonna save a
lot of money and you'll you'll live in a
nice house in about 10 years yeah I live
in an old ice house right now right now
yeah yeah at 25. it's it's funny because
it's like people will experience
cognitive dissonance
when they realize that sometimes like
[__] don't get a bad ending you know
everyone loves [__]
as long as and as long and if we can
create a safer space where we could have
better conversations about sexuality
where where women who admit that they
might actually like sex aren't punished
for it or receive consequences
the more honest of a sexual experience
we'll all have once we no longer have
once we have healed perspectives on
women and sexuality I know that people
are going to comment like this girl's
Twisted this girl's arranged I hope she
wakes the [__] up and as you're as you
were saying it it's directly a
reflection of how much
they don't understand why they don't
want to feel
sex like they don't they don't want to
embrace this feeling of being vulnerable
and yearning for something it's it feels
wrong it feels gross and a lot of that
is the way they've grown up whether it
was religiously or they've just grown up
with shame and rejection and they've
correlated that with women taking
ownership of their bodies but
I I just severely sincerely hope that
you just choose to be whatever the [__]
you want to be because that's the
bravest thing you can be and whether
that's a sexual being or not is up to
you but I am poor people to listen to
things they don't understand and not
want to kill them
earlier what's the downside of your
lifestyle I think the only downside to
your lifestyle might be
that you get so much judgment from
you know when you're trying to rent an
apartment from when you're yeah whatever
you know people figure out who you are
they might you might they might pass a
lot of judgment yeah I feel like when a
lot of sex workers become hyper
successful they forget what it's like
being the small guy you know being a
full service sex worker being a street
worker being being someone who doesn't
have as much resources to escape I can
talk freely about how much I don't give
a [__] about what anyone thinks about my
body or my life but that's because I'm
privileged enough to have the money and
and the like the resources and contacts
to be able to make sure that I'm always
going to be safe and I'm always going to
be respected but in all honesty
like
it's just it's just
all all of us just deserve respect it's
hard it's hard sometimes talking about
the good experiences of my sexuality
knowing that there are a lot of people
who suffer for it and as long as they're
suffering we're all suffering because
because a lot of especially a lot of
like what the internet believes about
sex work with it being
kind of condensed into sound bites and
not being multifaceted and nuanced
directly results in our violence and
misunderstanding
you're a very well spoken sex worker oh
thank you
thank you pretty impressive yay am I
making sense you're making perfect sense
yay I just don't I think people are
gonna have a hard time concentrating on
what you're saying though because of
what you're wearing
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in all of your
exploits
in 25 years 25 years you've seen a lot
everything comes to you but what stays
is what you allow I I obviously
experience a lot of hate and it's funny
I didn't when you first asked me like
what's a downside I didn't even register
it as a downside because
I just kind of just registered at that
as something I just obviously would
happen you know obviously duh people
would throw a tomato at me if they saw
me you know but it's just
everything comes to you but what stays
is what you allow
there's going to be much hate there's
going to be much Strife but there's also
going to be so many opportunities to
grow and so many experiences that you
you're going to regret saying no to so
as long as you
you decide what stays
you and you make sure what stays
respects you and makes sure that you
feel safe and supported there is
absolutely nothing wrong if you're doing
and I truly believe that and as I said
before like being yourself is the
bravest thing you can be if you're a
[__] and you love taking three dicks in
the ass you still deserve as much
respect as someone who doesn't and
you know and I would even say like
people who don't understand that I just
hope
that one day you feel comfortable in
your skin and you don't see people like
me as threats to your humanity and your
values because I can exist and so can
you
you know I've always wanted to do a
naked TED Talk
gets as many views as any Ted Talk just
get naked right here
it's what I've been waiting for
eign
didn't have to talk you into that yeah
I I feel like
I've explored a lot of nudist places
like I've been to nudist resorts and
there's like nudist cities like COPD and
like Europe and stuff country yeah and I
I even interviewed um some nudist people
on a jubilee video Once yeah so did I
did you really oh my God a bunch of
nudists I love nudists there's that
place in Black's Beach and everything I
like yeah Tampa and Orlando has a lot of
it's funny because as soon as I show
more skin I get taken less seriously
like it's it's like now that my tits are
out it's like harder to
to like
be understood it's like hey still here
I'm distracted
um but yeah I feel like I would really
love to do a naked Tech Ted talk because
there's a juxtaposition of like I need
you to take me really seriously but why
won't you take me seriously if I'm
[__] naked I get it yeah yeah
if you're pushing the
the understanding of of respect what
what sexuality is for a female
what role it has
yeah and it's like all the Judgment that
is associated to it it's like the
reverse it's like when you're nervous
and you imagine everyone else is naked
what if I'm naked I feel like I'd be
braver
I'd be like yeah I've been working out
um
yeah but I feel like a life mission of
mine is just showing that
you know I can be depraved and like
twisted and and I can still be just a
[__] person you know I like go to
Trader Joe's I buy the kimchi's pancakes
like everyone else like I just you know
I like like I said earlier you're
probably a great next door neighbor I am
a great next door neighbor you know I'll
be at the DMV waiting in line just like
everyone else I'm not any more insane or
inappropriate than anyone else is I'm
just brave enough to do your dog really
well if I had a dog yes I would treat it
really well
yeah
Kazumi you're amazing yay very
interesting thank you so much for
sharing your story and thank you your
lifestyle
maybe you've opened up some people's
minds we'll see
hopefully
thank you very much thanks for having me
sure yay